historic move expected today to try to
get soaring inflation under control the
federal reserve the country's central
bank and chief monetary authority
appears set to announce its biggest
interest rate hike in almost 30 years
the goal to slow down that surge in
prices on everything from rent and
mortgage payments to groceries and gas
without and this is the key part
triggering a recession nancy cordes is
at the white house for us covering all
of it nancy a lot riding on this a lot
of people paying attention what's the
plan
tony you know when it comes to inflation
there are a few tools that the white
house has as its disposal but the
federal reserve has a jackhammer and
it's poised to use that today
inflation it's sapping the strength of a
lot of families in philadelphia tuesday
president biden acknowledged the toll
high prices are taking
forcing families to spend nearly 350
dollars more per month than they did
last year to buy the same goods so i
have a plan to bring down the cost
of gas and food it's going to take time
the federal reserve isn't waiting it's
expected to raise interest rates by
three quarters of a percentage point
today the biggest one-time hike in
nearly 30 years the fed's got a pretty
tough job right so they want to raise
rates
high enough fast enough to cool down the
economy slow growth so that the economy
doesn't
overheat go past full employment and
exacerbate the high inflation that we
have right now but they don't want to
raise rates too fast too far and push
the economy into recession
tuesday's wild market swings ended down
fueled by fears the fed will go too fast
the snp is now officially in a bear
market down more than 21 percent since
january a new washington post poll finds
nearly nine in 10 americans have started
bargain hunting for cheaper products
nearly eight in ten are cutting back on
eating out and entertainment
the white house is urging congress to
pass funding bills that would ease the
burden by lowering the cost of child
care and prescription drugs but
republicans argue pandemic era stimulus
is already contributing to inflation and
they don't want to spend more washington
democrats have been wrong about
inflation from the very beginning
you know notwithstanding our efforts to
try and convince them that uh pushing
two trillion dollars out into the
economy
was going to be um was going to be
inflationary and create lots of havoc in
our economy uh they went ahead and did
it anyway
as the country struggles with record
high gas prices the white house is now
making it official president biden will
be heading to oil rich saudi arabia next
month now this is a big shift for
president biden who said during the
campaign that he would seek to make the
crown prince of the saudi kingdom a
quote pariah over human rights abuses
but now the white house says nate he'll
go wherever he has to go if it's in the
nation's interest
nancy thank you